we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a really great question about
the recent medical drama
uh
that i talked about yesterday
including uh the c-section birth of my
daughter and the re-hospitalization of
my girlfriend for a perforated uh
duodenum duodenum people were emailing
me saying sir you're pronouncing it
incorrectly
nuclear liberation yeah i'm doing my
best with pronunciations anyway here's
an interesting question about the entire
thing
hey david i'm glad your girlfriend is
all right
but i have a question
i don't know what type of health
insurance you guys have because you run
an independent business correct but how
much did all this cost
so how much were you billed for
um
last time i went to the hospital they
charged me ten thousand dollars
to go five minutes down the street yep
fortunately though i was on medicaid at
the time so i didn't have to pay for any
of it this is a great question ma we
have not gotten any bills yet okay i do
plan to open up the books like i did
after my appendectomy you might remember
my appendectomy it was about 40 grand of
which i had to pay my 2 000 deductible
okay
so
um indeed both both of us are
self-employed and so we
buy insurance from our state's
marketplace when back during my
appendectomy when i was in massachusetts
i bought i had a plan i purchased
through what's called the mass health
connector new york state has a similar
thing through which we now have our
plans called my state of health these
are not the best plans okay so my
expectation is
that
we are going to owe
the two thousand dollar deductible
for
the birth
and that associated hospital stay
the two thousand dollar deductible for
the re-hospitalization
for
the surgery
and then because of the ambulance call i
think that we probably have like a
man i don't it's probably a 500 copay
for the ambulance ride like these plan
these are not cheap plans and they also
cover very little
so that's what i expect to owe i think
our we're going to owe somewhere between
four and five thousand dollars for all
of this i think the build amounts could
could probably get to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
my understanding is that
c-section birth and subsequent
hospitalization
can be
80 grand or so
and then um
the surgery plus like a six-day
hospitalization after that in
i think it's considered sub-acute care i
don't really know that could be another
that could be a hundred grand 120 i
think that the the sort of sticker price
on everything is going to be somewhere
around 200 000 could even be a little
bit higher we will see and i expect we
will owe
somewhere around four or five thousand
so
i'll open the books when we get the
bills i haven't gotten them yet i'll
keep everybody posted we've got a great
bonus show for you today
uh with some horrible stories by the way
one positive thing is elizabeth warren
says democrats are only two votes away
from codifying roe v wade
is it too late well we'll talk about it
stacks of bodies have been found dead in
a trailer on the u.s mexico border
horrifying story and a study finds that
cannabis users are 25 percent more
likely to need emergency care
hospitalization but the question is
is it because of their cannabis use or
is it that people more likely to need
emergency care and hospitalization
are more likely to use cannabis which
would be a very very different
explanation all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad well i invite you to
sign up at joinpakman.com
get instant access to the david pakman
show bonus show thank your lucky stars
every day you're not dave bagman well
it's not that bad alex thank you very
much coupon code big voting22
sign up at joinpakman.com
i will see you on the bonus show